- [Interviewer] I'm sorry,
what's your name again?
- Melissa.
- [Interviewer] Melissa, Melissa.
Um, where are you from originally?
- Virginia.
- [Interviewer] Virginia. And
how long you've been out here?
- Since 2003.
- [Interviewer] Now, you're
living where in Skid Row?
- [Melissa] I stay with a
friend right here in the SRO,
on Sixth and Stanford.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see. Okay.
- But I've been in tents.
When I first come out
here, I stayed in tents
and hotels and just at random places.
- [Interviewer] Mm-hmm, yeah.
There's lots of different-
- I tried to get a residence.
I got an income,
but they put me on a waiting list,
and then they're giving me the runaround,
like, it's been taking years,
and it's (sighs), so.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So there's lots of drugs
in this neighborhood.
Are you into some of those?
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I use crack.
I've been using crack since I was-
Since, shoot, I guess '95, '94.
- [Interviewer] Right, so-
- That's the only thing
I use, though, but yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Usually people pick one
and they stick with that.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What age
did you start doing drugs?
- After I had my daughter,
when I was like 16.
I had her when I was I was 15.
- [Interviewer] Um, and then, like...
Tell me about your childhood.
- I had a good childhood,
just a normal little average childhood.
My mom and dad took
care of us really well.
We had everything we needed,
just the little middle-class family,
nothing big and extravagant,
but we were just average, you know?
Back in Virginia,
we had the little Christmas.
It would snow, and we went
sledding and all that.
- [Interviewer] So no,
like, child molestation-
- No. No abuse, nothing.
I didn't smoke cigarettes, didn't drink.
My father, mother-
No history.
Nobody in my family drank or anything.
Or even smoked cigarettes or nothing.
- [Interviewer] But you-
- And I'm the only one
that does it in my family.
My brothers and sisters don't do it.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- My sister smokes cigarettes,
but they don't drink.
They don't do drugs or nothin'.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think some of it is-
- They say it's because of me,
because I did it and they don't.
They hate 'em so much.
They despise it with such
an anger and a fierceness,
which I'm glad,
because they seen what it did to me,
took me away from them and
having a life with them,
and they miss me and all that.
How it put me in jails and locked up
and just all that stuff.
- [Interviewer] So your
daughter's how old now?
- She's 26.
- [Interviewer] 26?
- And I got a nine-year-old granddaughter.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
So some of the girls here are making money
picking up guys during the day-
- All of them. (laughs)
Most of all of them, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, pretty much.
That's what (indistinct).
The guys can't do it,
but the girls can.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] The girls
take advantage of it.
Have you done some of that?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've got a lot of
prostitution cases too, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Have you been to jail?
- Yes, numerous times.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Been to prison too.
- [Interviewer] For how long?
- Out here, I did 16 months with half.
Like, I did nine months for possession.
I got caught with a pipe.
It wasn't even no drugs.
It was just a pipe.
But my record from back home, really.
I was really off the hook, you know,
just outrageous, you know, so.
Prostitution.
I had violence on my record
and all that stuff, so.
- [Interviewer] Hmm.
- I'm not a violent person,
but I had to defend myself.
It was a dude, he got
obsessed with me and stuff,
and he kept attacking me.
And the police and stuff
wouldn't do nothing about it,
because, you know, who
I was and who he was.
His mom was an attorney, so.
And I was just a working
woman on the streets,
on drugs, so I didn't mean nothing.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So.
- [Interviewer] Pretty heartless.
- Yup.
- [Interviewer] Uh, what, uh?
Like, the kind of guys you'd pick up,
you must see all sorts, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me some of those stories-
- They got some weird ones, you know?
Like I had one dude that, um,
he wanted to put needles
through my bellybuttons,
and then he wanted to put, um-
He put, uh-
I was nodding off because
I had been up too long.
I was on drugs really heavy then,
and that's what really woke me up,
because I was nodding off,
and he was taking me to McDonald's,
through the drive-thru,
and I woke-
I came to, and I had shackles on my feet.
And I was handcuffed and shackled,
and I was like, I started panic.
I said, "Am I under arrest or something?"
But he-
The money was in the bag.
He's like, "No, the money's in the bag.
"That's just my thing."
He said, "I'm gonna come back
tomorrow and unlock you."
But he unlocked me,
but he left a lock on my ankle.
And I couldn't get it off,
and it was like (sighs).
I had to get my friend to cut it off.
He said, "Don't ever do that again
"because that's dangerous,"
you know what I'm saying?
And after that, I never-
I got plenty of rest.
When I used the drugs, I stayed at home,
and all that stuff, you know?
That really opened my eyes.
Because he did it to my friend
that passed away recently.
The guy across the street took
care of her until she passed,
recently got-
Not even a year ago.
It'll be a year ago in February.
Well, it was a year February.
She, um.
He put clamps and locks on her nipples,
and he didn't come back,
and they turned black,
and she almost lost her breasts.
He was really weird, though.
And the last time, when he-
He kept getting weirder and weirder
when he'd come through and stuff,
and so, the last time,
he gave me the money, and I was like,
"I'm not doing nothing.
"You causin' us a lot
of problems down here.
"You're very sick."
And he drives a Metro van,
works for the Metro, um,
transportation, the train.
And he pulled over there in
front of the (indistinct) place
and was like, "I'm gonna
get the police on you."
I said, "Go get 'em."
And when he come out, he said, "Moth-"
And he seen me, and he was like,
"Motherfucker, you were in a Metro van,
"a company van.
"You got a prostitute in the car.
"You running around here
trying to do weird stuff.
"We've heard about you.
"Get out here.
"I'm gonna call the
company right now on you."
And I said, "See there,"
and I jumped out the van.
And he ain't been back since.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(indistinct) got caught.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Then there's another guy
that kept me in the car.
This is the last story,
but he kept me in the car.
He tried to take me to the
place where he wanted me to go,
and I was like, "No,
I'm gonna go over here."
So he took me over there,
and he was getting on
top of me to have sex,
and he started choking me out.
And I started fainting.
I was going-
He was going to kill me.
I was going to die.
And I had a box cutter,
and I started sticking
him with the box cutter,
and he fell on his seat,
and he said "Oh god."
I said, "That's right.
"That's who you need to call on."
So I jumped out the car
and bust the window,
because I had my little radio like that.
And I bust the front windshield.
Well, he took off.
The next day, they found
a girl chopped in half.
One half of her was on
one side of the street.
The other half was on the other side,
the exact place where he tried
to take me to begin with.
- [Interviewer] Oh my god.
- He came back again and tried to get me.
And I wouldn't go with him.
But my friend bust his windshield out,
and he chased us in the street
and was runnin' over the
parking meters and everything.
Then we just called-
we called the police,
and they would not come
for like a half an hour.
Finally, once he totaled
his car, he took off.
The next morning, they found
a girl under the bridge.
Her stomach was tore
out, and she was gutted.
Every time he couldn't get
me, he got somebody else.
- [Interviewer] Wow. Have you-
- And he's still out here, I guess,
because they probably didn't catch him.
- [Interviewer] Gee, that's crazy.
- It's sad, you know what I'm sayin'?
But you say, God had to
have been with me because...
that was a sick man.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- They had another girl.
She was out here.
She had-
Her hands was like this,
but she was a working girl,
and her son had brain cancer.
And she was workin',
and she was sendin' all
her money back there
for him to get treatments and stuff,
back wherever she was from,
and this dude took her and chopped her up.
My friend got in the car with him first.
It was a van.
And she felt funny.
She said, "I gotta pee."
So she got out the van
to pee and took off.
And then she went and
got in the van with him,
and they found her chopped up on Olive,
in all the trash cans, body parts of her.
Her body parts by the trash cans,
all up and down Olive Street.
He got her, and I was like...
- [Interviewer] Jesus.
- There's some sick people.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Melissa] You just really
have to go with your aura
and your feeling.
You have to stay sober
and stay in a level mind
and have a clear mind
when you go out there
and be very aware of what's goin' on.
And you feel the difference.
You feel it from people.
But when you're on them drugs,
your mind's just thinking
about getting the drugs.
You're high, you're twisted, this-
And it's-
And it is a big difference.
Because I can see 'em comin'.
When they even pull up to me,
I'll be like, "Look, I'm good, I'm good."
I could feel it.
I could see it in 'em.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Melissa] And people say,
"Uh, uh, it's gotta be somebody else."
No, it's not.
Because if you sit there
and you pay attention,
you've been in the
streets as long as I have,
you know the difference.
You know the signs.
It's a psychological thing
and a spiritual thing.
You can know.
You just look for little
things, little au-
It's just little feelings
you can't explain,
like, 'cause I feel 'em
when they're coming.
And they see me, they say-
They know they ain't got me,
you know what I'm saying?
I can look at them and
see, they're like (sighs).
Like "Oh her, huh?
"She ain't goin' for it."
(Interviewer laughs)
You know, like a evil spirit.
People don't believe in the spirits,
but it's a real world.
Spiritual world is really real.
And it's really scary,
but there's been some horrific
stuff that happened out here.
- [Interviewer] What's
your tattoo on your chest?
- [Melissa] That's my
husband's name, Abdee Shakur.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
- [Melissa] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You still married?
- [Melissa] Yeah, he's-
Matter of fact, he just got out.
He's getting out this week.
But he's back east.
It's a long story.
We come out here, and he got
hit and ran over by a car.
- [Interviewer] Hmm.
- And the dude was tryin' to kidnap me.
Well, he was trying to go with me,
and my husband was scared
he was gonna kidnap me,
so he jumped on the truck, fell off,
and we ran over him.
He ran over him with the truck.
I thought he was dead.
The man was gonna kill
me and took me under-
He took me under the bridge
and was gonna kill me,
but I jumped out of the truck and ran.
- [Interviewer] And what's
your husband in jail for?
- Murder. He went back
there and got involved
with some female, and
they had an argument.
And he was supposed to be goin' back
to get physical therapy
and come back to get me, his wife,
but he had an affair, and...
They got into a fight, and he
went and shot him in the face.
To his door-
Knocked on his door and
shot the man in the face.
I said, "How in the
hell can you shoot a man
"in the face over his wife,
"and you left your wife
"on the other side of
the fucking country?"
So I just don't get it,
so that's another issue I gotta deal with,
because I'm, you know,
I gotta get the divorce.
He wouldn't do it.
He wouldn't go for it when
I served him the papers,
so I don't know.
I gotta go through all that shit again.
...Talk about him.
- [Interviewer] So crack,
do you shoot, you smoke-
- No, I just smoke it.
- [Interviewer] You smoke it?
- Mm-hmm. I will never
put a needle in my arm.
I can't.
It was hard gettin' tattoos.
And then, when I went to jail,
I seen all-
When I first come out here,
I seen all them girls.
It's a long line you gotta stand in,
and the smell is, oh god, overwhelming.
They have abscesses and sores and stuff.
And their socks have
matted onto their feet,
into the sores, and ugh,
just pulling them off and-
Ugh!
It's horrible.
(Interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] When you're in jail,
you can't get your drugs,
so you had to go through withdrawal?
- Well, no.
With crack, you don't
go through withdrawals.
You probably have a little
moods 'cause you're cranky,
whatever, no.
Physically-
It's not physically addictive.
- [Interviewer] No?
- No. Just heroin.
It's physically addictive.
- [Interviewer] Hmm.
- You know, they-
A lot of people die from it,
the withdrawals is so bad.
But they have diarrhea,
vomiting, all this.
They're miserable.
Yeah. (mouth click)
- [Interviewer] Do you wanna
get off it at some point or-
- Well, I can get off of it.
And, I mean, I've done it before.
It's just something to do right now,
and it's so easy to get it, whatever.
It's just something to do.
It goes with the territory right now, but-
Because when I'm ready to put it down,
it ain't no lookin' back or whatever.
But I got plans and stuff
that's gonna happen for me,
so this-
You know, I'm not gonna
be one of these people
that's been out here 40 and 50 years,
and some of 'em, they're 70 years old
and been out and raised their
kids down here and stuff.
And now their kids is down here,
like generations of people are down here,
and it's like, that's fucking crazy.
That's sad.
And they're proud of it.
They're like, "I'm a downtown, baby.
"I'm a DTG, baby."
I'm like, "Well, that's really sad,"
because they're proud of it, but...
Maybe they understand it.
I don't.
- [Interviewer] (indistinct)
- Yeah, it really is.